No, I was surprised that it was quite early
. Did you start a Japanese dentist? Oh, and
I can't believe you can get cavities at this price
. Is it more expensive in the United States?
I'm surprised.
No, the Japanese insurance system
has a wonderful access card.
I'm sorry I
can't use a credit card here
. I'm David. I can't use David either. Our hospital is
only cash.  But it's
almost the same as beat and cash.
No, I
'm sorry for the inconvenience.
Yes, thank
you. I'd like you to go
smoothly or make a reservation for the next time.  I won't throw it away, so
yes, Mr. Gen-san still has three cavities,
so what was the next time
? I have to do the top and bottom separately because of insurance.
It's a problem
today.  I'm taking a break from work, so
I have to finish everything by the end of the day, and the next
customer is already waiting, so I'm not sure if I'll
take another break next time
.